alright so I think maybe we go back
inside look look oh wow just does that
sometimes we're back inside as a
building and see if I can get a scan of
my teeth from the computer or something
generally I'm not going now you still
think I'm locked up well of course they
do um their own super can break in
upstairs hey see maybe one of the
windows is open and then we can access a
computer and maybe is it good hey climb
that yes uh okay um yeah maybe it's like
a DA to file my teeth that they knew you
know something not only no man no it's
closed ex ex ex ex it's locked so look
they oh they all look locked this isn't
good don't use freeze for it no use for
it mm-hmm this one of them yes I am
correct
boom this isn't my office no I'm in here
oh yeah to get drunk obviously yeah
party time okay so something in this
here what what what is it is it photos
of your mom naked I don't it looks like
a glowing honker glowing hunk of coral
the [ __ ] would I need that for no
messages and Dom's fancy Richardson come
I can't even imagine I put the Carl away
no more Carl and then we'll try to guess
his path okay why would this have my
teeth I don't know maybe it's his teeth
Elias nope it's not goose I can't oh
maybe there's like a secret is somewhere
that has his password a anything else
that I can interrupt this is punched the
thing hmm blue thing moved what's that
let's be honest it just looks like a
pixelated heap of nothing what even is
that yeah damn I don't had this in his
mouth I'm mouth guard hey that's how
it's gonna work that's a mouth guard or
anything else in here doesn't seem to be
looking at anything else I probably
shouldn't go out there as he say oh oh
no did you just get stuck my cankles
drawings were booked all right well I'm
gonna try and guess it's possible again
just for good measure I'm gonna try to
guess his password
mmm and it's not mr. Dean try again more
I say so much for da me a feeling its
probly not gonna work back out we go all
right um I me okay so I have a piece of
coral [ __ ] do I have a piece of coral
for a piece of coral and a mouth guard
sir I think if I come down here and give
them z mouth guard what do I have coral
full I still don't even know what he's
the bread on I guess his buds up fam you
have to use the one on them sometime
agent gala beta here agent got all
barrel here it's like not a very well
hidden secret base there let's be real
it's so [ __ ] oh yes okay mmm know if
God I can pull up on her shoulders oh
yeah the war mouth God preez hey captain
that's not its mouth got time mouth got
I'm gonna use it you just wipes it on
himself I know we've been on it okay
there you go mmhmm yeah well now I know
what Domino taste yeah what's that dumb
nose mouth piece they can get a dental
impression off of it no the plastic so
hard you didn't leave a mark what uh
so we need a dental impression how how
how do i what um I have no idea what I'm
supposed to do you I have to fill this
with something so that I can bite on it
um that was liquid back in the garage
that random thing walkman I don't know a
man alone i'm so glad i can run now oh
my gosh so the place where I was locked
up I had a thingy in it hey what did
they do this thing oh I was right okay
and then fill adept good for dance great
why is it even in here I can in fight it
fight it fight it Manny so it wow that
made a perfect impression of my very
subtle and quite a chalky after please
do chalky is that I don't know that's
not necessarily bad adjective is it yeah
oh he looks up when you guys plus you
what are you looking up at I don't want
to mess up my tooth caster care
let us give them your tooth cast [ __ ] do
I views the coral for I'm so confused
right now right meow got something here
that might agree yes everything's
working
okay we give this to the lady hello
Manny this looks like a perfect
impression of yes we can use this as a
mold to make a fake set of teeth and get
into the computer system and why she
couldn't do it any wager cuz you know
salesman sorry whoa what now what one
now what else is ever that I was
supposed to do anything did I mention
has been great working with you ditto
kid what am I supposed to do new mm okay
okay I mean what do I have to do I'm
going to build an underground army of
souls to fight the injustice i have seen
in El Masri invocation will become vital
as a lost souls Alliance spreads out
we'll need messengers we can trust okay
you want me to be your messenger no my
way our numbers are small and our agents
are too valuable to risk that solemn
work history shows only one messenger to
be of use to a cause like ours carrier
pigeons a pigeon's time so I release the
bread for the roof will you let me go no
I need to raise them from birth agent
color I need you to bring me their eggs
okay keeping me here because you need
eggs why are you still here today go get
me an Air Force before it okay sure I'm
off their well Legion calavera and viva
la revolucion okay you seem to be doing
a lot of standing for someone who's
really passionate about a revolution you
ain't doing [ __ ] okay do I have enough
Fred how is word gonna get me eggs
though I still have no idea what's a
service exam and I don't gradual ations
domino on your new job oh I steal it
from him I guess do we have bread yes
one bread the only one bread okay you
know that's a lot of risk-taking let's
go get some more
Mel bread please I just take a little
more bread to honor not a little more a
lot more be a very good usurpation there
one was there remember grace let us go
and give bread to birds I could crash
shut up put it away I hate that that's
okay the thing that I like the least
about this game is the fact that he
doesn't some automatically put things
away dude dude okay
uh hmm how do I get on the roof maybe
I'm just supposed to mmm give it to this
little guy you want some bread buddy hey
you want to spread I get crumbs all over
oh those are some ugly directly ties
believe I climbed up that thing you
can't believe you cleaned up that thing
what are you looking at it and is there
anything else we can do with it no don't
climb back down ah some what I want I'm
sure and pick it up that's what I want
to try back off damn it
doo doo doo doo de doo de doo de I
really like that's good music I'm gonna
pick it up somehow without climbing down
pick it up can you yes and then thrill
it's perfect ha uh what um I what put
bread on the a
huh [ __ ] what am I supposed to do here
create an anchor I got to put an anchor
on it right
like leave it that yes okay and then
we'll get well maybe that's what wow
that looks like a [ __ ] Anka I was
gonna go with the fire extinguisher this
totally looks like an ankle yes throw
this thing I go that's how Domino men to
do B doesn't matter domino's a dick yeah
you clip through that wall yeah you
throw that thing you all be asleep in
halting okay let's go s
don't do it really well today already up
y'all yes um he looked up there what was
it gosh it's bad
come on buddy you can do faster than
that come on but hello oh my god why are
you running please run he won't run oh
he's just walking by himself it's a
cutscene right there we go hello oh oh
that sounds bad oh oh we're gonna attack
me pull myself out yes excuse me birds
prepare to die oh so they chased me away
go around this side maybe what's this I
don't want to mess up my blade he's
looking at that Iran let's put it
reaches obviously yes let's put bread in
it and lure them away ah yes and you the
print would come in handy and then
they'll come to it and I'll run over
there go for it go for it amigos I knew
you owned it yes what I can't I can't
move when that happens what the hell you
mean what what that did not go according
to plan they just go and eat it and then
go back am I supposed to put like poison
in it or something